All right,
busy political week.
Let's go to the phones and see what's on people's
minds.
Uh, at six one seven, eight, three zero 47
50.
Let's start with our caller from the seven
seven three area code.
Who's calling from seven, seven three today?
Seven, seven three.
Yes.
Go ahead.
Hi.
Um, my question is basically about the democratic
priories.
I want to know at what point do you think
that you're sewing Jew, the mainstream it
is going to get behind Bernie and start supporting
him cause I'm seeing headlines like a consensors
maintain this momentum or you know, Sanders
went in New Hampshire shows that there's a
split in the democratic party.
Like do you think there is a point after X
amount of primaries where they're going to
start getting behind him and actually being
supportive?
No, probably not.
I, I wouldn't.
Um, I don't think that they're going to now
I think that really the question is when,
when will the legacy corporate media and DNC
decide is is Biden their candidate or is it
going to be P boot edge edge or Amy or if
Michael Bloomberg does well on super Tuesday,
will they switch to Bloomberg?
But I don't expect them to get behind Bernie
at any point soon.
Are you, I mean, are you in favor of Bernie?
I know you, you've made videos saying you're
not a socialist, but I mean, is Bernie your
pick?
Yes.
Yes, yes.
I said earlier this week at this point in
the Massachusetts primary, I plan to vote
for Bernie.
I believe that at this point, this is a race
between Biden maybe, although increasingly
he's not going to be a factor P boot edge,
edge.
Um, I do believe Bloomberg is going to end
up third or fourth in delegates.
Uh, so yeah, these are the people that basically
now are, this is, this is down to a, so I'll
be voting for Bernie in the primary.
Okay.
And um, the last question I have, um, kind
of a silly one.
I, I've only been a fan for a few months,
so I don't know, maybe you've covered this,
but did anyone or make fun of your last name?
Sorry you did.
Did anyone make fun of your, your connection
is maybe a five out of 10.
Did someone make fun of my last name?
Yeah, when you were younger.
Um, I mean people would say, Oh, did your
dad invent the video game or whatever.
And for a while it annoyed me and then eventually
I would say yes, he did it completely.
I would just say yes he did.
And then it very quickly ended the conversation.
Okay.
All right, well thanks.
It was great
talking
to you.
All right, thanks.
I appreciate the phone call.